yeah I started doing experiments in
chemistry we never saw each of about 12
or 13 in she stays no computers were
available and I was always very bad in
sports so it was playing the piano so I
was interested in music but apart from
that I was interested in science that's
why i started with chemically
experiments i had a very wonderful book
called chemical experiments that work at
so i started to lose his experiments in
my bedroom but one day my mother said
you should stop said it smells over ways
so terribly until I'm afraid one day in
the morning you will not wake up anymore
and that's why I stopped chemical
instrument experiments and moved into
physics whenever you solve a problem
work answer a question you had are faced
with two or three new ones of course you
always need some some some fantasy to
imagine what could be the answer to this
question yeah because in this defines a
lion on work along which you are doing
your new research I think it's always an
adventure to ask a question and to enter
a new field where you don't know the
answer in advance and if you then get an
answer and if this answer is really
surprising this creates a great chair
joy always many many people approach you
and want answers to questions you never
had solved before it don't know quite
different things I can imagine yet yeah
and you must be very careful with your
answers pinned because they can be used
and or two to the mass of sources and
since they are completely turned around
to hear an experience which I never had
before of the christmas i will be to
retreat into my resort and then stay
there for week or so and just think
overall as a whole situation
you